foreign
ERS welcome to how the light gets in
thank you one approach of the left and
especially in the US I think when it
comes to reactionary right-wing ideas
and the people who hold them is to
avoid them avoid giving them a platform
avoid talking with them avoid engaging
with them and the argument is you're
only going to end up propagating their
ideas right you're someone who takes
very much the opposite view of this and
even though your politics are very much
on the left you choose to go
head-to-head with people whose views to
put it mildly you disagree with right
what do you think is the value of that
kind of Engagement and what are you
hoping to achieve with it sure so I
think the impulse to you know not give
people platforms
both uh I think both shows a kind of
disturbing lack of confidence uh in our
own ideas
and also just doesn't really make sense
to me mathematically uh that it seems
like oftentimes we're talking about
people who already have much larger
platforms you know than than we do and
so the idea that if you just sort of
studiously ignore them and not give them
the magical Aura of your uh of your
presence you know that that'll decrease
their influence doesn't really make
sense I think it makes a lot more sense
to
you know to go out there and you know
present your ideas uh to uh to people
who might not otherwise be exposed to
them especially because we've you know
we're at an incredibly fractured media
landscape where oftentimes this is the
only way you can ever talk to anybody
else's audience and what do you have to
achieve when when you argue with these
people I mean I imagine you don't think
you're going to change the Mind
necessarily as I hope that people
watching it that aren't really already
part of the tribal divisions are going
to somehow take something away from it
yeah I mean the goal is never to
convince the other person on the stage
or the person the other half of the
YouTube split screen or whatever uh-huh
that because that's realistically that's
probably not going to happen uh people
whose personal and professional
identities are wrapped up and promoting
um their point of view do sometimes
change their mind but it's an incredibly
slow process at that point it's almost
like experiencing religious conversion
and it's probably not going to happen as
a result of one conversation Nation uh
so and the goal isn't even to reach
their most hardcore fans uh for the
reasons you you kind of hinted at in
that question that that's also probably
not a realistic goal but any audience of
any size whatsoever is composed of lots
of different groups of people and so you
want to reach whoever's persuadable in
that audience that could be curious
fence sitters that could be people who
you know you debate in Charlie Kirk
there could be people who you know kind
of like what he's saying and are willing
to give him a sympathetic hearing but
aren't really marriage these ideas yet
it could be people who used to be
hardcore fans but you catch them at
exactly the right time you know in the
ark when they're open to something else
YouTube has been known as this kind of
like radicalizing platform do you think
it also acts now as a kind of the
opposite as a deer radicalize people
that already have sort of views that are
quite far out there
yeah
um
it can I think that the enemies
certainly anecdotally you know I mean I
I hear from people all the time
um who who have moved to the left as a
result of you know things that they've
you know they've watched on YouTube that
they think that's played a role
so you know it certainly can I mean I
have all sorts of issues with the way
that those platforms work and you know
and I if I could somehow magically get
my way you know I think that there just
wouldn't be
um you know I'm kind of an algorithm
abolitionist you know I think they just
wouldn't be recommended videos you know
you'd have to uh you'd have to search
for things but uh given that it is what
it is I think it's a space that it's not
helpful to concede to your ideological
opponents you are a defender of free
speech and a Critic of those who argue
that you know platforms like YouTube or
Twitter or Facebook should regulate
speech online ban certain forms of
misinformation band session forms of
conspiracy theorizing do you think the
left is on the wrong side of the
argument when it comes to free speech
especially with online platforms yeah I
think many uh many progressives even
many people with like seriously
left-wing views
who end up sort of tailing the liberal
end of the culture wars on this issue
uh how incredibly short-sighted about
this you know that uh so even though you
know what they would call misinformation
which is a word I kind of hate because I
think you know lying is a perfectly good
word uh just believing dumb things is a
is a perfectly understandable concept
but misinformation is the sort of
unhelpful pseudo-technical term that
sounds like it identifies something very
clear but my problem with it the reason
I think it's so short-sighted is that
every political argument is to some
extent an argument about the facts that
uh you know people who you know people
who want to raise the minimum wage and
people who don't disagree about whether
that's going to lead to more
unemployment you know people who want to
you know escalate the conflict with with
Russia you know are less likely to think
that that's gonna uh that's gonna lead
to the the threat of world war three the
people who don't etc etc that's always
going to be true like there's no
political argument that's only an
argument about values not at all an
argument about facts so both sides will
always from their perspective think the
other is guilty of you know
misinformation whatever that means and
so the question is as always with free
speech I think who gets to decide right
you know who gets to decide what's uh
what's true and what's misinformation
and I don't really trust any institution
you know with that power even if even if
YouTube and Spotify and Twitter were run
by you know some committee that you know
represented working class interests you
know like I still wouldn't trust them
but I particularly don't trust them
because they're actually owned by
Massive profitable corporations that
have every incentive to oppose the
platform of the serious left they they
don't want to give up their money and
who have every incentive to stay on the
right side of the National Security
State so you know one way of kind of
bringing all these threads together is
to ask like okay if uh social media as
we know it had existed in 2002 and
um they had you know strict policies
against misinformation who'd be more
likely to be booted for misinformation
people who agreed with George Bush Tony
Blair in the New York Times their
weapons of mass destruction in Iraq or
people who didn't
around the time that Elon Musk was
pretending he was going to buy a tomato
we don't know whether he's actually
going to do it you wrote an article
saying despite the fact that he has this
kind of position of absolute free speech
that that wouldn't really help Free
Speech why did you why did you think
that yeah so I think it's possible that
if Elon Musk actually did go ahead with
the purchase I think it's entirely
possible that there would be moderation
policies there uh For Better or For
Worse I doubt that he would do exactly
what he was saying but you know they I
think it's entirely possible the
policies would change in a direction I
would like but the point I was making in
that article
is that
um one I don't particularly trust him on
this I think uh if you look at his own
history
of Union busted if you look at his own
history of being very hair trigger about
suing people for libel uh I don't
particularly believe that he would uh
that you know maybe he would surprise me
but I I would be very unsurprised if he
wasn't quite good to his good you know
good on his word on Free Speech policies
on Twitter but that's you know I could
be wrong about that the larger point the
more important point to my mind is that
it's kind of absurd that you should have
to hope that some benevolent rich person
is going to buy the digital Public
Square and that they're going to allow
lots of free speech there I mean you
know as if in actual literal Public
Square as we lived in some sort of you
know libertarian dystopia where those
were profitly owned and so you could
only hold a public protest March if the
particular sidewalk you were you know
marching down happened to be owned by a
free speech billionaire instead of an
anti-free speech billionaire that that
seems like a a very short-sighted
solution to me so you know my have good
results but I don't think we should have
to count on that I think we would be
much better off
having democratically accountable
institutions around these platforms you
mentioned earlier that political
disagreement isn't just about values
it's also about facts is disagreement
about the facts increasing or was this
always a part of politics and we've just
somehow gotten onto the fact that that's
the case I think it's always been part
of politics I think it might be
maybe like a little bit more obvious or
disturbed in some ways now than it was
like
in 2002 for example so I think that now
there's just a different problem with
media that the problem with media in
2002 was more or less all the stuff that
like Noam Chomsky and Edward Hermann
were talking about in the 80s you know
manufacturing consent
um you know that certain you know that
there was this uh you know mainstream
media that was incredibly powerful that
excluded voices that shouldn't be
excluded and was too credulous about
government claims and things like that
all entirely correct criticisms but
that's just not the problem that we have
now right the problem we have now is
that traditional media has economically
collapsed it's incredibly fractured
uh it's in many ways returned to its
roots you know that we sort of had this
idea of politically neutral media as a
sort of mid 20th century invention and
you know and we're reverted into an
older form of media that's very
fractured where the economic incentive
uh given that you know five percent as
many people are watching you know Rachel
Maddow or Tucker Carlson or whoever has
watched Say Walter Cronkite you know
back when the economic incentive is to
relentlessly Pander to whatever audience
you have left which means that there's a
lot of incentive for reporting even the
Wisp of the rumor of something that fits
with your preferred narratives and a lot
of disincentives for correcting it when
you find out you know that it's not true
so I think that you that certain kinds
of arguments about facts are more
frustrated now probably that they were
20 years ago but I also don't think
there has it was ever a time when
arguments about facts played no role in
political arguments I think that's
always going to be there
our culture wars based on a disagreement
also about facts or are those really
truly only about values
yeah I don't think they're only about
values I think that in fact very often
times uh cultural or spats are fueled by
uh people having very different
impressions of facts that you know
there'll be some high profile trial that
you'll you know that you'll get
completely parallel universes of
people's perceptions of what's going you
know what's going on in them they'll get
very mad at each other about this and
then at the end of the day you know like
there is no
um you know in terms of policy there's
no there there random trials don't set
legally binding precedence right it you
know what happens with you know I don't
know Johnny Depp and Amber Heard only
affects Johnny Depp and Amber Heard like
you know literally and nobody else but
people still you know people still fight
about this
um and it's in a lot of ways it's this
sort of strange symbolic pseudo-politics
right you know Politics as I would
understand it is about what the laws are
how material resources are distributed
and note of that is actually at stake in
in any of this I mean it's I think in a
strange way because there's so much
information everybody's fingertips all
the time and so much chance to sort of
signal your allegiances you know by by
who get us through your media
preferences but also most Ordinary
People are largely disempowered in terms
of institutional things that affect
their lives the combination of all this
is that everything is political but none
of it actually matters very much
is there a danger of dismissing culture
or Politics as irrelevant as kind of
politically frivolous and pseudopolitics
when especially the U.S
some of the key cultural issues and
things like abortion and gun control
really do end up affecting sort of how
people's lives are run yeah so I'd make
a distinction between social policy and
culture right so I think that you know
battles that are fought literally over
what the laws are whether you're allowed
to get an abortion whether you're
allowed to you know sell 18 year olds
AR-15s
are not the same thing as fighting about
cultural sensibilities which would be
probably culture we're properly speaking
although they're fought as proxies for
the culture War so I think
that for example you know it it's you
know the reason why
uh you know Republicans in Florida you
know passed uh the uh the law against uh
teaching anything that had anything to
do with sexual identity or sexual
orientation
uh in um in early grades of in early
grades of school wasn't they'd like
received a bunch of reports about this
happening and you know and and they
decided that you know something had to
be done about it you know it was for the
sake of scoring points about the
cultural set you know sensibilities but
sure once you do that then you have a
real issue and and that could be very
bad you know you could you could imagine
all sorts of ways in which
you know under that law that example you
know that uh that the teachers could get
fired for you know doing all sorts of
innocuous things uh and the attack on
public education and that need that does
need to be thought about but even there
I would say that you know recognizing
that a lot of these social battle policy
battles are often fought as proxies for
the culture War should impact how we
think about them which is not to say
that the left can be neutral on them I
mean there are issues of principle here
um but I think it does impact how you
think about issues of emphasis because
battles over cultural sensibilities do
tend to polarize people in a much more
evenly split way whereas battles about
distribution and material resources at
least have the potential to build you
know much larger majority Coalition so
without giving anything up on the you
know the substance of it right you know
I mean that again you know there are
issues of principle if you believe women
have the right to control their own
bodies you know you you have to oppose
you know attempts to roll back abortion
rights but I think strategically it
could still make a lot of sense to try
to focus as much as possible on the
kinds of battles where uh I think the
last message is going to be most
compelling to the most people and how do
we move the agenda away from the kind of
cultural issues that just divide people
so tribally and onto the kind of
economic agenda one part of that
specifically on the left the Electoral
front uh is that you actually do have to
give people something that they can get
excited about about the material issues
I think it's a little much to hope that
if you're you know six percent better
than they have in the opposition on the
material issues uh that people will get
more excited about that than they do
about you know cultural tribalism
um but I also think that not all the
answers electoral I think that you know
I think that a lot of it has to take
place
um you know in the workplace as we're
having this conversation uh there have
been several hundred Starbucks stores in
the United States that have uh that have
been have unionization efforts you know
going on at them right now
um there was there was just the first
Amazon you know Warehouse that was
unionized uh and this is the kind of
thing because it affects people's
interests and the most immediate
visceral level you know that they am I
going to get paid more you know uh do I
is it going to be easier to take time
off you're going to spend with my family
I think there's much greater potential
for uh for winning over people whose
cultural sensibilities might put them at
odds that the left uh in the that first
ever Amazon warehouse that was unionized
uh one of you know even though uh the
main organizer Chris Smalls is a black
radical leftist uh you know he's given
credit to this uh this Amazon warehouse
worker who refers to his Uncle Pat who's
an Italian-American Trump voter on
Staten Island uh who signed up several
hundred people uh for uh for the union
because even if you like Trump because
he triggers the libs you know you uh you
know you might still like to have more
bathroom breaks and be paid more money
among other things you're a philosophy
Professor is a room for philosophy and
contemporary politics or is that too
idealistic and naive to believe I think
you need to fire on both levels so I
think that it's
um I don't I'm under no illusions that
99 of political persuasion is going to
take place at the level of like
you know well worked out intellectual
arguments
um you know you know you have to have a
version of that that trickles down to
the point of like Punchy easily
communicated things but I actually also
think it's useful to have a version of
it that is that is well worked out that
they uh that you know if you're
you know trying to convince a lot of
different people uh who um who are going
to ask different kinds of questions and
you know and and be you know be engaged
with different kinds of arguments I
think it's useful to you know I think
it's useful to have some people who who
do each some people uh some people who
do both do both you know I mean I think
that you probably don't get me wrong I
think that you know I think the left
probably needs more you need an
organizers than philosophy professors
but I don't think it's bad to have a few
philosophy professors left-wing policy
is supposed to be sort of
forward-looking but they often have this
kind of whiff of the past you know ideas
from the 19th century economic ideas
from the 1960s and 1970s and that in
some ways allows people to dismiss them
as kind of irrelevant to the 21st
century caught in the past trying to
resurrect an economic World in reality
that no longer exists so what's your
vision for left-wing politics of the
future that sort of is a genuine
orientation towards
the future not the past yeah I mean I
think that
um you know I think that for most of the
couple thousand years between the end of
the Roman Republic and the French
Revolution uh anybody who was talking
about a republican form of government
you know was talking about things that
uh that hadn't existed for many
centuries
um and you know surely if the mid to
late 19th century had gone you know had
had gone a different way and the sort of
world that meter dick presided over you
know was more or less the one we were
still in then you know then say ah you
know we tried some of this democracy
stuff in the early 19th century you know
it didn't go anywhere why why are you
still stuck in that you should be
talking about some slightly different
form of monarchy because that would be
exciting and new and Progressive I think
that I think that the the Left Right
distinction that I care about is about
how
um how equal you know a society how fair
a society you're living in and uh you
know to uh you know to the extent uh
that you know the society you're living
in has gone in the right direction then
going even further you know we'll seem
you know Progressive in that
chronological sense uh to the extent
that it's gone in the wrong direction as
it has in the last several decades of
neoliberalism that it's uh it's going to
it's going to seem backward looking but
I don't really care about forward or
backward I care about you know more
egalitarian or less
Ben Bridges thank you very much thank
you so much
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to The Institute of Arts
and ideas at IAI TV